los plásticos y micro plásticos están en
todas partes en el suelo en el aire pero
especialmente en los océanos las miles
de toneladas de plástico en los mares
contaminan sus aguas y se introducen
hasta en la cadena alimenticia de los
animales y se han realizado varios
estudios en diferentes laboratorios
desde filipinas hasta california hasta
las islas galápagos y en norteamérica
que evidencian que el plástico que se
descompone en por el calor por la sal
del mar por el agua etcétera y los peces
y los organismos que viven en el mar
confunden con plancton y constituyen
comida para ellos los océanos cubren el
71% de nuestro planeta y proporcionan
más de la mitad del oxígeno del mundo
por lo que su deterioro es una amenaza
para la humanidad cada año 13 millones
de toneladas se acumulan en los océanos
siendo el 90% de estos micro plásticos
imperceptibles a simple vista pero que
tienen un 3
impacto sobre la biodiversidad marina y
sus ecosistemas las fuentes de
contaminación son diversas desde redes
de pesca olvidadas en el mar hasta
plásticos de uso diario como botellas o
tapabocas una problemática que algunos
gobiernos están intentando afrontar a
partir de 2021 la unión europea planea
prohibir algunos plásticos de un solo
uso aunque los expertos animan a ir un
paso más allá también lo que estamos
llamando el sirio west es decir que
desde el principio no tengamos tienes la
necesidad de producir y consumir y
desechar ese es el gran principio que
deberíamos
enfrentar la humanidad en plena lucha
contra la pandemia los tapabocas de un
solo uso han ayudado a salvar muchas
vidas pero también afectan a la salud de
los océanos el año pasado más de 1500
millones de mascarillas contribuyeron a
la contaminación plástica del mar